all right let's get into audience
questions for the week very very good
questions came in this week first and
foremost David which would be more
damaging to Donald Trump if released the
PP tape or his tax returns this is an
incredibly easy question to answer in my
mind the tax returns the tax returns at
this point the PP tapes if the PP tapes
were released and by the way if you if
you don't know what I'm talking about
with the PP tapes the PP tapes refers to
recordings that may or may not exist of
Donald Trump engaging in urine related
sexual escapades in Russia that are
referenced in the Christopher Steele
dossier and of course the steel dossier
doesn't say that the tapes exist the
steel dossier says that some of the
sources for that dossier said that it's
possible that such tapes exist
or that such activity may have taken
place between the people who will simply
write it off as doctored video and those
who simply don't care what it is that
Donald Trump did ignoring of course
whether he's been lying about this stuff
all along and the reality that tons of
people voted for Trump despite the fact
that he did much more what's the word
worse things I mean in the end if Donald
Trump is into whatever it is that he's
into sexually it doesn't really relate
to who he is as a president making fun
of disabled people not knowing anything
about economics and trade and all of
that other stuff that's really bad
that's really the stuff that we should
be concerned about so the tax returns
would undoubtedly be much worse for him
than if the PP tape exists and was
released because if he went so far as to
despite overwhelming desire from the
American people to see his tax returns
the fact that 40 years of presidential
candidates nominees from Democratic and
Republican primaries release tax returns
if he didn't do it despite all of that
stuff it's because on some level he
he suspected or knew that the release of
the tax returns would be worse than the
bad press for not releasing them the one
exception would be if it's simply he
didn't want people to know that he's not
nearly as rich as he claims to be that
would be the one reason for not
releasing them that actually wouldn't be
that bad it just shows how sort of vain
and naive not not so much naive but
really just vain and and sort of pompous
and self-aggrandizing Trump is that
would not be quite so bad but there is
no question in my mind that the release
of the tax returns would be worse if you
disagree if you think that the release
of the pp tapes if they exist would be
worse for Trump than the release of his
tax returns please let me know I want to
hear from you because I just don't see
it